Leo everybody aspires to be debt free
and to pay off their mortgage and to own
their own home you got there what did
that feel like did you feel like you'd
arrived at the top of the ladder and I
think it was comfortable I could remain
mortgage free but still have to work
until the virtually the day I die so you
basically bought a house for 11 Grand I
see some of the younger kids on the
academy with no money and they've
started and they're just sort of
Smashing it you've bought some houses
you've acquired a asset and you're now
financially independent we're still
going to be 3 000 pounds better off this
has been the first thing in my life that
has worked
I want to talk to you about property
investing hey when did you first start
getting into property and what was it
that got you interested during the
pandemic really frustrating I didn't
know what to do but you know I could I
could guess you can't pay a country for
two years with the economy not tanking
and I was actually I was really fearful
and frightened for that so my first
thing I'd seen some of your YouTube
videos
and I just thought okay I've got an
opportunity here take the plunge
refinance my flat so that was the way I
got some money and I was able to put
that on a deposit for my first
bog standard safe buy to let I didn't
really know what I was doing
um lots of people and family thought
around me thought you know you know I
was nuts so what was the rationale
behind refinancing your home because
most people tend to want to pay off
their mortgage so for you to actually
release Equity from it and have more
debt to then buy a second property what
was the rationale what was the reasoning
behind it the rationale was being
exposed to other possibilities that I
hadn't previously known about and one of
those was
the the power of Leverage and using a
mortgage other people's money to maybe
get a to get a second property because
you know that can be a cash producing
asset that's the important and just
trying to learn with the difference
between what is an asset
um and what actually is a liability but
as we've seen all of our working lives
all of my working lives property overall
tends to go up
there's that saying it's safe as houses
I mean sometimes it goes up sometimes it
goes down but the important thing was to
just just get something out there and
just try and hedge against inflation
that was my that was my my fear and my
rationale with that first one and being
a school teacher because that's your
background is it well I'm a care worker
actually care worker yes so I look after
adults with learning disabilities and
dementia right in it you know that kind
of with your family being a care worker
um it's very normal to get a job pay off
the mortgage build into a pension this
is what we had been led to believe our
entire lives
um so massive lot of unlearning for me
to do and go against the grain you know
you know and they are they work they're
saying what are you doing you're
mortgage free
Where Are You Gonna why are you doing
this but I could yeah I could remain
mortgage free but still have to work
until virtually the day I die just to
keep up with you know the cost of living
I mean we're seeing we're seeing that
now and you recently got a promotion at
work as well yeah yes just got a
promotion as well that's part of the Rat
Race that's part of the Trap you kind of
you you know it's like oh you know at
what point can you get out of it so you
can either swap your life
uh for that nine to five you know five
days a week for your entire life or is
there another way can you change your
life can you take control of your life
can you get educated and so that you can
actually break out of that trap Leo
everybody
aspires to be debt free and to pay off
their mortgage and to own their own home
you got there you worked hard for many
many years and you bought a house and
you paid off the mortgage and you were
debt free
what does it feel like what did that
feel like did you did you feel like
you'd arrived at the top of the ladder
it was a weird feeling I mean my you
know my flat was all paid for
um
and I think it was comfortable you know
and I think what is really easy to is to
remain in that comfort zone you think
okay I'm sort of managing you know
you've got a little bit extra at the end
of each month but really that is it you
can't not work you know you would have
to be going back to work on that Monday
morning because you yeah you've still
got your your um utilities your food
yeah and everything's going up and this
is scary and really hard for lots of
people out there I'm just sort of
grateful that you know was able to just
do what I did just in time but I think
you know any time is a good time to
start yeah you know I don't think you
can wait for the change you know wait
for things wait for the perfect time
is never going to be perfect you've got
to get out there you've got to have the
courage to do it you might have to have
the courage to go against the grain of
your friends and family and I think what
you need to do you just gotta
you don't know what you don't know and
you've just got to get yourself educated
as best as you can plug into some
positive people so that you can have the
confidence of your own convictions so
you can move forward now in the last
couple of years you've got into property
as a as a business yeah you've bought
some houses you've taken out you've
acquired assets and you're now
financially independent yeah which it
almost doesn't seem real yeah
um it is uh you know from seeing how
that first uh buy to let worked after
that I went to one of your one pound
crash courses which was like a pretty
unique experience if somebody hasn't
been to one of those before get along
um
sit there
soak it all up you might some of it is
gonna land on you some of it's gonna go
over your head but you just have to I
would just say to anybody
go along what have you got to lose a
pound
a pound
for
possibly a life-changing experience
where you could learn a couple of
nuggets or a window of your life could
be opened so after after going along
there I think I went along to a couple
and then joined the academy the
difference that that has made is just
the uh there's so many different things
that you can do with property
um there is no one right way or better
way there's just different ways I see
some of the younger kids
on the academy
uh with no money and they've started and
they're just sort of Smashing it I'm a
bit older I'm coming at it from a a
different angle uh where I am lucky
enough maybe to have had you know a
refinance but flat had a bit of cash and
there were different strategies so my
strategies were just trying to get a
property or two
um but after seeing uh you know learning
what you can at the courses
um not necessarily just doing a standard
buy to let you could do and it would
work but there's other ways where you
can get super rent as you say which is
might be serviced accommodation
um and that's where you're sort of uh
get a property
um when you have it like um like a mini
hotel and that could be like an Airbnb
or so you know um where people come
along and they pay to stay for a night
or two some people I've just had some
people in and they've stayed for
two months
um
at a much higher rate so you know there
are ways that you can really
um uh multiplied that income yeah and
and that's what you've been doing a lot
of you've been renting out your
properties now moving forward as service
accommodation and short stay that how's
that been playing out for you that's the
thing that has got me to this stage
where
um yeah I'm sort of technically
financially free it's a real Buzz I
actually love doing it and um from my
family and friends thinking like I'm
some kind of fruitcake uh they're now
looking at it thinking oh my gosh
I had this actually this thing works
yeah
um and I think it it pretty much can
work it anywhere where there are people
so unless you've got you know a fair
amount of people around
um and you would think who's coming to
stay people some often think it's just
holiday makers or something it's not you
get holiday makers you could have
contractors you could have people
visiting family or relatives
um it there there's a whole a whole
range of reasons why people might come
and stay yeah and you've got some
properties that you've bought and you're
renting out a service accommodation
you've also taken on properties as rent
to rent and now you're buying a a guest
house my partner has has seen how well
you know the you know my little service
accommodation things work
um and um so we're looking to
possibly kind of I suppose a joint
venture on a sort of bed and breakfast
and and am I right in saying that your
partner is also similar to yourself she
has a house she paid off the mortgage
she's got a few hundred thousand pound
house and now she's thinking hang on a
minute if I sell or if I refinance this
house yeah I could use the money to buy
an asset because this is the thing
sometimes people will be worried about
refinancing their existing house because
now they're going to stop paying
mortgage payments again yeah but if you
use the money to buy an asset then the
asset can pay the mortgage payments and
way more well this is the thing you keep
doing the numbers and you know you work
it out on the worst case scenario really
just if it works on the worst case
scenario
um you know and you're still looking at
it and I keep thinking checking it and
double checking it thinking what have we
missed but for example she has to get a
mortgage she might have a sort of seven
700 pound mortgage a month
but we keep doing the numbers
on you know the asset uh the the bed of
breakfast
and at the worst case scenario it will
net 3 000 pounds a month so out of that
you pay your mortgage well you just I
said I keep we keep looking at it I said
we're still going to be three thousand
pounds
the better off yeah and and have that
and that
you know together with what I'm doing
that's a life-changing situation for us
um and would be for anything and
something that um
uh well so far we enjoy doing yeah and I
think people are sitting in equity they
might even if they've not paid off their
mortgage if you've got a house worth 300
000 and you've only got a small mortgage
of maybe a hundred thousand or fifty
thousand the idea of reef as long as you
know what to do with the money once you
refinance really important I think you
know don't you know this is not a
question of of being irresponsible or
willy-nilly nobody nobody wants to get
into debt
but again as you've all often said
there's good debt and there's bad debt
good debt is something that you know is
an asset that it produces some an income
uh bad debt is something that you've got
and you're just paying out of and it's
just sort of draining away so no you've
got again you've got to be responsible
it's like there's a saying give a sprout
to catch a mackerel if you have to
remortgage your house your Finance
refinance your house
don't do it to buy a holiday or go get a
car that would
that's not the idea if you but if you
refinance your house and you might be
paying an extra
a few hundred pounds a month on a
mortgage
but the thing that you bought or you've
swapped it for
you can live in or you can rent out and
and it's paying you
back the mortgage plus a thousand pounds
or something yeah or 1500 well suddenly
you've got
you've got that extra Finance yeah
that's absolutely right what do you
think about interest rates though
because that's really hurt a lot of
landlords and now if you're if you're
refinancing your house to buy other
properties there's a lot of landlords
that aren't making any money at all so
how do you make sure that you are in
good monthly profit because you're now
making a full-time salary yeah with just
your passive income from properties yes
how do you make sure that your cash
flowing positive well one of my
properties I've got to be honest I on
the very last property so I've got two
that are doing fine but my last one
um I came close to coming unstuck that
was a particular property that was
difficult to purchase I had three
mortgages that expired and this was when
the rates were good
and at the end of the day I just thought
the only way I could do this is with a
bridging loan to just get it over the
line and this is where again it takes a
bit of time it can take a bit of
tenacity
um and you have to know what you're
doing but also you can't rely on
solicitors or accountants or anybody
else often it does come to you to shovel
it over the line literally got the
bridging line got the property right in
the middle
um of just getting that
um
there's that change of government they
had the the mini budget that put
interest screwed everybody screwed
everybody through you know just
everything went through the roof and and
I'm thinking ah what's gonna happen here
manage to refinance it and and literally
just sort of come out of that okay the
rental is just just about covering
things yeah but nothing like it would
have
but I was able to pull out
um
two-thirds you know two-thirds three
quarters of the deposit so how much did
you buy it for probably for 140 and then
how much did you spend on it refurbing
it probably about two and a half
thousand so say you bought it for 140
one for 140 and then you spit a couple
thousand on it and then what was the end
value 180. so there's 38 Grand and then
have you refinanced it so it's
refinanced it was able to pull out about
twenty three twenty four thousand so how
much money did you end up leaving in
about 11. so you basically bought a
house for 11 Grand yes and that's the
point that's the point everybody
suddenly
you got a property
that's actually cost you eleven thousand
and you think in in those terms yeah
there's a mortgage on it but if the
mortgage is being you know paid for by
the tenant or however you're renting
that out you've acquired an asset a
property that over time likely to
increase
um but you can you have the control of
it so at the moment it's it's I've just
got a tenant in there but I think in due
course I'll get I'll look at maybe
seeing what else we can do with that you
know maybe service accommodation and do
some service accommodation with that one
how do you get around the tax rules like
for instance section 24 which again only
came in in 2020
um that was when it came to full effect
which is absolutely crippled landlords
how are you getting around the taxes so
ideally you buy these in a company right
um so with a company you can offset
um all of your mortgage payments and all
of your costs and things like that
because I didn't know what I was doing
in the early days some of mine aren't in
a company so you know I'm sort of you
I'm paying for what I didn't know yeah
yeah and I think we all end up paying
something one way or the other not that
you either pay pay to learn or you're
going to pay you know over a period of
time with what you don't know what did
your partner think when you went to the
crash course because I think you you
kind of mentioned that it was a little
bit weird because I was sort of teaching
everything opposite to what you'd
learned all your life in your normal
background I'm saying you know don't buy
a house to live in don't pay off the
mortgage everything I'm saying about
Finance is completely different and a
lot of people like yourself are thinking
um really should have done what you know
you can't it's so difficult to get your
head around because it's just like
you've got a lifetime of what you've
been you you've we've all been taught in
the system you know which is you know
would go to school study hard you know
or get a degree get a good job you know
keep working your way up the ladder and
then you can retire and look nobody's
saying that there's anything wrong with
that sure but when you have had a
lifetime of that and that has been the
environment that you've been you've
you've lived your whole life with
um that in a sense is that is quite a
lot of baggage to try and
and learn and I think that's so for me I
think that's why
um uh
it's been a bit of a slower process you
know it I haven't gone as fast as as
I've seen other people go
um but it literally I've just had to
it's been a process to unlearn all of
this this stuff and everything the media
says it's almost opposite if the media
is saying house prices are crashing
now's a bad time that's normally when
actually the rich people are investing
in property yeah when the media and the
Taxi man is saying now's a great time is
usually when we're being a bit more
cautious everything's opposite
everything's opposite and and I think
that is where you know you one has to
you've got to learn
to you know we can do a couple of things
in life you can either follow what
everybody else is doing and end up
pretty much like everybody else and just
do the norm or maybe you can look at uh
a small percentage of people that are
not doing they're not playing by the
rules they're not doing what necessary
Society or the government wants you to
do and I think half the time
it's a belief thing it's really
believing this is really possible you
can really what me as an ordinary person
who's like worked all his life
for other companies and things can
actually sort of step out and and do
this you mentioned as well about the
it's only a pound and what's the worst
that could happen you lose a pound you
know everyone should come to the crash
course yeah absolutely I think what
always strikes me about this is that
there's every kind of there is no one
set person there's no one type it's it's
the biggest widest demographic of people
I've ever seen
uh and that's at any of the events Ricky
will come out and do a bit of teaching
and then you'll come out and
um uh and start on these sort of
different strategies and different ideas
and they're coming at you so fast
you're you're thinking that's a good
idea oh yeah then there's another
another strategy you think oh no that's
a good idea too and then there's another
strategy
I think that's a good idea actually
they're all bloody good ideas and they
all work it's just picky you know it's
just working out what what's going to be
right here like how you bought a
property and then you refinanced it
that's like a bit of a brr yeah
potentially renting out a short stylets
and the strategy is all link I think
that's it it's so multi-faceted there's
so many different
opportunities and options
um that they do all link into each other
and you might start off with thinking
you know that you're going to do one
thing but something else crops up and
you just think I mean I'd never intended
to have to try and refinance that house
because I I never imagined that I'd have
three mortgages fall through yeah after
then get a bridging loan if I hadn't
what would have happened the deal would
have fallen through how many properties
have you got in total now including my
own residential I've just got four and
three of them are service accommodations
yes and you're making a full-time income
off of that how much time do you have to
spend managing the portfolio so I'm
still working full-time in my normal job
so
um managing it probably
um
an hour or two a week so you're only
spending literally an hour or two a week
managing the portfolio yeah and you're
making a full-time income now from your
from your property portfolio what why
why have you continued working in your
job because I know you don't have to
financially you don't have to do that
anymore partly because I feel like I'm
I'm just getting to a cusp of
the next level right
um and something happens when you become
when you when you start earning
the same or a bit more of money outside
of your normal job than there suddenly
your main job
um doesn't seem quite so bad anymore oh
really interesting and I think the
psychologically is because you now know
that you don't have to do this you've
got an Escape Route right
um
so this doesn't mean to say that one day
I'm not going to give it up or anything
but right now
um I still consider myself in the early
stages of my property Journey but
actually whilst you've got a job it is
easier to get a mortgage yeah uh on a
standard residential
um property they just like it the
systems and the banks and everything and
the mortgage people they just they like
it it doesn't actually make sense that
they like it so much
it's just the system that they operate
in it's just what you said about a job
though I was I was in the sauna the
other day and I was in the Sun for about
probably about five or ten minutes it
was really hot and then I suddenly had a
vision that the door might be locked
and the only thing worse than me really
hot in a sauna it's been really hot in
the sauna known the door's locked
because if the doors locked
psychologically it's like
oh get out I have a job it's to say if
you're in a job and it's like I don't
particularly like it but there's no way
out you're trapped horrible huh but if
you know that the doors open and you can
leave any time Suddenly It's like
actually I quite enjoy it in this honor
that has suddenly made the difference I
think it is about suddenly this can give
you options yeah and opportunities and
if then you can choose
to do something or not
there is a game changer there is one
part of me I do know that I'm sort of
thinking yeah man if I was doing
property full time they I'd be I'd clean
up I'd be I kind of do no 10x your
income probably yeah well that might be
the next stage of your journey we'll see
how things go but right now being at the
point of financially independent yeah
and and making a full-time income for
property passive basically yeah it's a
big achievement how did you justify
joining the academy and spending
thousands of pounds on your education
how did you justify that decision I just
thought if I can pay that money
and in a year
I could be financially free in effect
and by that I mean basically at least
earning at least as the same as my day
job what would that be worth to me what
would difference would that make to my
life otherwise I'm going to be still
working until I'm 67. I just thought I
haven't got that much time left
um
I've still got
I've still got it in me to to have a
crack at this you know I've tried to
I've been in business as other my own
businesses before and different things
but they've been more retail so this was
um
this has been the first thing
um in my life
that has worked
and
I'm just pleased that
kind of got I feel I've got got there in
the end I'm not there where I want to be
you yeah but at least I've kind of
bloody well got over the line that's
what I feel what did your partner think
when you first joined the academy and
when before you'd actually see any
results I didn't tell her
not initially but she must have knew
that you're in property and yep she did
you know not just her a few people
around at the time suddenly thought
what's happened with what's happened to
Leo he's just gonna like obsessed with
property
he's upset all the time almost as though
there was something wrong with me
um which there probably was I was
thinking gotta do something because the
storm's coming and if I don't do
something now it has come and the storm
has come it has and that's why lots of
people now are absolutely screwed
because the average salary
isn't enough to pay for the average rent
and bills and food it's not enough no
it's got to be difficult for an awful
lot of people out there did you set up
an alert on your partner's phone
so that every time you got paid in
property it would ping talk to me is
that true yeah that is true
um that is true because I just thought
uh how am I going to
share that this is that this this is
working so so yeah so I set up my set up
a service accommodation things I said
can I put you I'm going to put you as a
co-host because I'd already realized
that every time a booking comes in the
phone pings so she can see these
bookings coming in so with my partner's
phone started pinging all the time but
that was a massive
massive thing about getting her on board
and just showing her
and anybody else that this that it
really does work well Leo really
insightful really inspiring and massive
well done you deserve every success
you've worked hard and it's just been
great working with you I've had a lot of
fun I hope you've enjoyed working with
me oh absolutely absolutely what can I
say wouldn't be here now wouldn't be
able to sit here and have this chat with
you which is just which is just great
um if it wasn't for you
and the academy and all the other
Academy members never in my life
have I experienced
you know such a nice bunch of people and
I think maybe the one thing that might
just make the difference is that the
people that turn up to those crash
courses or go on the academies
have got that something that something
possibility they want to better
themselves they want to just try and
improve things and um and it's just a
great opportunity and a great platform
and a great place to do that so thank
you very much yeah thanks for your time
if you're watching this and you want to
come and join us join the community one
pound come and spend the day with me the
team learn get an action plan put
together of how you can smash it in
property investing this year I'll leave
a link below it's one pound what are you
waiting for get book now let's smash it
[Music]